remember that massive twitch hack that
leaked the earnings the platform's top
streamers but now several streamers in
turkey are being questioned about their
earnings as well as some admitting to
their involvement in an alleged money
laundering scheme so what happened and
how did allegedly 10 million dollars get
stolen
[Music]
hey y'all before we get into the video i
gotta remind you as always to hit the
subscribe button ring the notification
bell and don't forget to leave us a like
and comment now let's get back to the
story so y'all before we get started i
just want to say that none of us here at
the square esports speak turkish so i
reached out to sinan kuyunju who is a
turkish esports journalist he helped me
fact check my information provided
translation provide context as well as
additional information this video would
not have been possible without him so a
huge thank you to him so remember a
while back when a hacker posted a quote
extremely pogers leak that leaked the
top streamer's income from the platform
people memed on streamers for a week and
then everything just kind of died down
but it hasn't completely died down in
fact for the turkish community
it's done nothing but become bigger
turkish streamers are now being accused
of participating in a money laundering
scheme via stolen credit cards allegedly
someone would have the stolen credit
card information use the credit card
information to donate to streamers
and then the streamers would send some
of the money back to the original donors
aka the person who stole the information
this is done so it is unclear where the
original source of the money was it's a
win-win for these two groups everyone
would be making money and no one would
be losing anything because the money was
stolen except for the person's credit
card information that was stolen they've
been losing lots of money without their
consent this my dears is a form of money
laundering if you're not sure what money
laundering is that's okay let me break
this down for you money laundering is
where someone gets money whether it's
stealing or some other illegal way then
sends it through a bunch of different
channels and places so you can't tell
where that original money came from and
then that money eventually returned to
the original thief you might have heard
about it like the way i did when turkish
valorem players like cned were
questioned about their involvement in
this we touch on this do not jump to
conclusions right now so how did this
alleged money laundering scheme come to
light on october 23rd on the night
online forum a forum dedicated to the
mmorpg night online a document was
posted that compared the followings of
streamers the money that they made as
well as conversations with a quote bit
provider the post said that smaller
streamers were making insane amounts of
money via bits compared to their
viewership the numbers just didn't add
up the streamers were far too small to
be making so much money xenon explained
to me that the original post has been
deleted due to threats that were made
but it has been reposted a second time
with new names added this time no
conversations were included to help put
this in perspective according to middle
east eye quote some were found to be
earning up to eighteen hundred dollars a
day despite having just forty to fifty
viewers the money was being made through
bits if you're not sure where bits are
that's okay just know that one hundred
bits is equivalent to one us dollar you
donate bits and sometimes you get little
fun rewards from your streamers a skit a
gag or sometimes a sound queue whatever
basically it's like any other donation
with your money for those of you who are
not understanding why this is such a big
deal that is a crazy amount of money to
be making despite having such a small
amount of viewers after the initial
information came out a big streamer in
turkey named durane was made aware of
the list and tweeted about it on october
23rd including the claim that this was
happening via stolen credit cards duran
has about 600 000 followers on twitter
and 1.7 million on twitch cenon
explained to me that this is when the
story really began to spread durane's
tweet made people aware of the situation
beyond just the original post and the
night online players with so many
earnings not making sense and alleged
conversations about this donation
process people began to dig basically
there was some smoke and people began to
look for the fires duvar english the
english language source for turkish
online news site gazette duvar
specifically reported that according to
drain the streamer after receiving the
money pays their predetermined
commission generally 20 to 80 percent or
50 50 to launderers through the crypto
wallets so with this alleged scheme if
you were the perpetrator this is how it
all go down you would steal the credit
card information use that information
donate bits to a streamer that streamer
would send you some of the money back to
be clear i'm not saying to go out and do
this please do not commit crimes another
streamer named grimnax tweeted out
screenshots of discord messages which
allegedly showed discussion about the
money laundering scheme taking place
grimnax declined participating in the
scheme and then made a joke in the tweet
that he must have been a bad streamer
since he only offered him a 20 cut
another streamer quote tweeted gerain
and shared screenshots that seemed to
corroborate what drain was saying
showing discord messages that allegedly
show a conversation about bit donations
this tweet is from someone who allegedly
shows a credit card transaction that was
never authorized by them it's reported
that up to 10 million dollars was
laundered through this alleged scheme
duvar english also reported that in
another interview drain said that this
has been going on for years grimnak
seemed to confirm what duran said about
the length of time this has been
happening when they told the publication
middle east eye that quote this is
something that many of us have been
aware of for a long time but we couldn't
confirm twitch and the owner amazon nor
the audience for years we waited for the
prominent names on the platform to talk
about this issue as i mid-level
influencers like me weren't loud enough
so what has been the outcome of all of
this well a lot has happened since the
story first emerged so please bear with
me the calls for information and justice
actually grew to such a large size that
members of the turkish government began
to take notice politician names and i
apologize for butchering this name
gersol teching has called for
investigation and used the trending
hashtag hashtag temi's twitch or
cleantwitch another politician showed
support for the hashtag tami's twitch
movement on twitter a journalist also
reported that the parliament speaker
said they would be looking into the
events xenon told me that it looks like
an investigation was officially started
a twitch spokesperson also said in a
statement that quote recently members of
the twitch community have expressed
concerns toward the legitimacy of some
creators revenues in turkey we want to
assure our community that we do not
hesitate to take decisive action against
accounts engaged in prohibited conduct
we take efforts to combat and prevent
financial fraud on twitch on a regular
basis and in september alone we took
action against over 150 partners in
turkey for abuse of our monetization
tools duvar english have also since
reported that turkish schumer's
boycotted the platform until november
5th and that the rai games manager of
turkey said that they are aware and
monitoring the situation what started
out as just a forum post has become a
much bigger affair a turkish streamer
who was speaking about the situation p
queen said she was doxed live on stream
when someone donated bits and revealed
her phone number and her address super
massive blaze an organization that has a
prominent eu val roster announced that
they had parted ways with two players
but did not name them other orcs have
also parted ways with some of their
players related to the alleged scheme
xenon told me that acute streamers have
denied these allegations saying that
they were not aware of this stolen
credit card information a statement that
supports this was released by bbl lego
who has since been let go from his org
saying that he did participate in the
scheme but he was told it was completely
legal at first he then says he tried to
leave when the donor was anonymous but
he was unable to leave right away as his
growing popularity was used as blackmail
against him he also says that he was not
aware that the credit cards used were
stolen but what about cena like i said a
lot of you may have heard about this
story with the accusations being leveled
against him
was he accepting money from these
alleged money launderers and their
stolen credit cards his team ascend
which some of you may know as when the
16 teams competing in vct champions
released a statement regarding cnn's
involvement in the statement they said
that cena received one donation from an
account that has now since been
connected to the scheme they say that
cned was not in contact with the
perpetrator nor did he report the
donation to twitch which he now believes
was a mistake at the end of the day this
is all alleged there are no official
results for an investigation but if and
when those results become public we will
update you on them
i found xenon on twitter
and i just saw he worked for a turkish
esports outlet and i dm'd him and i was
like hey i should make sure i get this
right are you willing to speak to me
about this and he was so kind and so
patient and so understanding he he just
was translating things for me without me
asking this is a scene on stand club i'm
the president of the scene on stand club